the policy has been passed
overwhelmingly for our innovation agenda
we even with the opposition of the
Republican leadership we had a majority
of the republicans voting with us so
from a policy standpoint has passed the
Congress that was called it competes act
it's paying for it that is a problem for
the President of the United States they
don't pay any bills and so these
investments in research and development
and education that are essential to the
innovation that our country needs need
to be paid for we put some money of that
into the supplemental calling an
emergency put it in the supplemental not
enough but a signal that science and
research and development is essential to
innovation and we intend to follow
through
you